TONIGHT, VLADIMIR PUTIN WARNING
THAT TODAY'S MISSILE BLITZ THAT
HE LAUNCHED ON UKRAINE'S QUOTE,
NOT ALL WE CAN DO.
THIS AS 55 MISSILES RAINED DOWN
ON KYIV AND OTHER CITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WITH AT LEAST TEN
STRIKING A MORE CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE ARE OUT FRONT TONIGHT FROM
KYIV.
[NOISE] >> LIFE JUST GOT HARDER
IN KEITH, MONDAY MORNING 80% OF
THE CAPITALS WATER OFF.
FOLLOWING A NEW BARRAGE OF
RUSSIAN AIRSTRIKES.
SPIGOTS, NOT USED SINCE THE WAR
BEGAN, A LIFELINE AGAIN.
BUT NOT UNEXPECTED.
>> EVERYONE WHO IS IN KYIV
RIGHT NOW, AND THEY CHOOSE TO
STAY HERE, THEY ARE READY FOR
THIS.
>> THEY WON'T MAKE YOU LEAVE
THE CITY?
>> NO, I WILL STAY HERE.
I DIDN'T LEAVE IT SINCE THE WAR
BEGINS.
I HAVE TO DO IT NOW.
>> DESPITE THE LONG LINES IN
SOME PARTS OF THE CITY,
PATIENTS ARE PLENTY.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
MAYBE THREE HOURS, MAYBE NO
WATER.
AFTER 20 MINUTES.
>> IT'LL BE OKAY.
>> SCENES LIKE THIS ARE
BECOMING INCREASINGLY NORMAL
ACROSS UKRAINE.
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS SAY THAT
THERE WERE TEN DIFFERENT
REGIONS TARGETING MONDAY.
18 DIFFERENT SITES.
AMONG THEM, A HYDROELECTRIC
POWER PLANT, UKRAINE'S BIGGEST
IN ZAPORIZHZHIA, AN HOUR
THEY'RE POWER JIM SITE IN
CENTRAL UKRAINE.
THE SUBWAY IN THE EAST, STILLED
BY STRIKES ON VITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE.
AND DESPITE INTERCEPTS, 44
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, ACCORDING
TO THE GOVERNMENT.
GROUPS OF MISSILES GETTING
THROUGH.
AT LEAST THREE ACCORDING TO
THIS WITNESS, NEAR KYIV'S HYDRO
ELECTRIC POWER PLANT.
A MISSILE THREAT THROUGH OVER
OUR HOUSE.
I WENT TO THE BALCONY, I SAW
THE SECOND MISSILE IN A DRONE
SHE SAYS, BOTH WERE FLYING IN
THE DIRECTION OF THE POWER
PLANT.
IT IS SO SCARY WHEN YOU SEE IT.
THREE WEEKS OF TARGETING
UKRAINE'S ELECTRICITY NETWORK
IS PUSHING THE POWER GRID
TOWARDS A TIPPING POINT.
NO DOUBT MORE OF THIS TO COME.
>> THE MAYOR OF KYIV EARLIER IN
THE DAY PRACTICE --
HE PROMISED THAT HE WOULD GET
SOME OF THE WATER UP AND
RUNNING.
BY THE END OF THE DAY, WE ARE
TOLD THAT IT IS ABOUT 60% BACK
UP.
SOME THAT LEAVES ABOUT 40% OF
THE CITY WITHOUT WATER.
BUT THE POWER SITUATION IS MUCH
MORE DIRE.
RUSSIA HAS REALLY REDUCE THE
CAPACITY OF THE SYSTEM HERE.
ONE OF THE BIG ENERGY COMPANY
BOSSES HERE SAID THAT THE
DAMAGE IS INTO HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF SPARE
PARTS THAT THEY DON'T HAVE IN
THE COUNTRY ANYMORE, WE HAVE TO
REACH OUT TO ALLIES AND
PARTNERS AROUND THE WORLD.
IT IS AT A POINT WHERE A COUPLE
OF STRIKES MAKE A HUGE AMOUNT
OF DIFFERENCE AND THE ABILITY
OF UKRAINE TO GET ANYTHING BACK
UP AND RUNNING.
THAT IS PUSHING OFF IN THE
DISTANCE RIGHT NOW.
>> NICK, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT.
I'M GONNA BRING IN RETIRED ARMY
LIEUTENANT GENERAL MARK FOR
THIS.
GENERAL, IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WE HAVE SEEN RUSSIA REALLY
ESCALATING THESE ATTACKS.
NICK HAS BEEN DOCUMENTING THIS.
YOU SEE A LARGER STRATEGY IN
TERRORIZING THE CIVILIAN
POPULATION OVER AND OVER AGAIN?
>> IT HAS BEEN HAPPENING FROM
THE BEGINNING, KATE.
IT IS ACCELERATING RIGHT NOW.
NICK JUST MENTIONED ABOUT THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT TAKES TO REPAIR THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
RUSSIA IS ALSO SPENDING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON A
STRATEGY OF ATTACKING CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE, FORCING THE
ZELENSKYY GOVERNMENT TO LOOK
INTO DIRECTIONS.
THEY WANT TO CONTINUE THE
MILITARY ASSAULTS ON THE
RUSSIANS THAT ARE OPERATING
TRYING OUR COUNTRY, BUT THEY'RE
FACED WITH THE DYNAMIC OF HOW
DO WE TAKE CARE OF OUR
CIVILIANS AT THE SAME TIME.
IT CAUSES THAT GOVERNMENT TO
LOOK TWO WAYS, THIS IS
UNFORTUNATELY MORE A
CONTINUATION OF AN ILLEGAL
STRATEGY BY MR. PUTIN, WHICH IS
BASED ON COMMITTING WAR CRIMES.
YOU CAN'T SAY IT ANY OTHER WAY,
I KNOW I'VE BEEN A BROKEN
RECORD ON THIS, BUT THAT IS
JUST THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER.
>> WHEN IS THE REALITY, IT'S
NOT A BROKEN RECORD.
IT'S GETTING WHAT THE REALITY
IS ON THE GROUND, I WANT TO
PLAY FOR YOU SOME NEW VIDEO
THAT CAME OUT FRONT.
I KNOW IT ALSO GRABBED YOUR
TENSION AS WELL.
YOU CAN SEE IT ON YOUR SCREEN,
HOW IT APPEARS TO SHOW RUSSIAN
FORCES COMING UNDER ATTACK AND
IN THEIR FRIEND HIM ATTEMPT TO
FREE THE LINE OF FIRE, YOU CAN
SEE MULTIPLE SOLDIERS PILING ON
TO THE OUTSIDE OF THE MILITARY
VEHICLE.
THE TANK IS SPEEDING AWAY, YOU
SEE RIGHT THERE, IT THEN
CRASHES OFF THE SIDE OF A ROAD.
CNN CAN'T INDEPENDENTLY VERIFY
THE VIDEO, BUT IN SEEING THIS,
GENERAL, WHAT DO YOU SEE HERE?
>> WELL, YOU ARE SHOWING THE
WHOLE QUID NOW.
YOU ARE SEEING UNDISCIPLINED
SOLDIERS ACROSS THE BOARD.
SOLDIERS FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING WHO HAD JUMPED ONTO
THIS VEHICLE WITHOUT UNIFORMS,
THEY HAVE HAD THEIR HELMETS
ASKEW, SOME OF THEM HAVE
BASEBALL CAPS ON BACKWARDS.
THEY ARE HANDING MORE ROUNDS
INTO THE COURT OF THIS VEHICLE.
YOU ARE HEARING THE TRACK
COMMANDER SAY, HANG ON, FIND A
PLACE TO HANG ON.
SOLDIER SAYING, I DON'T KNOW
WHERE TO HANG ON.
THE VEHICLE TAKES OFF, YOU ARE
SEEING SOLDIERS LOSING THEIR
HELMET AS IT FLIES DOWN THE
ROAD.
THERE IS NO WAY, THERE'S HELEN
THAT JUST WENT OFF.
THERE'S NO WAY MEANT FOR THIS
VEHICLE.
THEY GO OFF IN A DITCH PROBABLY
CAUSE SOME OF THOSE SOLDIERS
THAT ARE ON TOP OF THE VEHICLES
ARE BLOCKING THE DRIVER'S VIEW.
IT IS A COMEDY OF AIR.
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT SOLDIERS LOOK FOR IN AND
ON DISAPPOINTED, CHAOTIC MOB.
NOT A GROUP OF SOLDIERS.
THIS IS JUST REPRESENTATIVE OF
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN AND
UNTRAINED FORCE FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING, WHERE IN THIS CASE,
I'M SURE THERE WERE SOME
SOLDIERS EITHER BADLY INJURED
OR PERHAPS EVEN KILLED WHEN
THAT VEHICLE ROLLED OVER.
IT WAS JUST BECAUSE THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW TO PERFORM THE KINDS
OF SKILLS THAT ARE EXPECTED OF
SOLDIERS ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
THANKFULLY, THE UKRAINIAN FORCE
IS MUCH MORE DISCIPLINED, THEY
HAVE AND AND CEO CORE THAT
ENFORCES STANDARDS AND THE KEY
THING IS, WINTER IS COMING.
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT, RIGHT
NOW IT IS 38 DEGREES IN KYIV.
IT IS GETTING COLD, WE ARE
STILL IN NOVEMBER.
THE KIND OF DISCIPLINE THAT IS
NEEDED ON THE FORCE RIGHT NOW
HAS TO BE APPLIED BY